hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
ultra high content imaging a breath of
fresh air for lung cancer research
i am jennifer woods of lab roots and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths and brought to
you by miltonie biotech
to learn more visit
www.miltonebiotech.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting
any questions you may have during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or
hearing the presentation i'd like to now
welcome our speaker
dr thomas santos global product manager
for ultra high content imaging
at milton yi biotech dr santos you may
now begin your presentation
hello and thank you for signing up for
this webinar
in a previous webinar my colleague
stefan eylitz presented next generation
ultra high content analysis of the tumor
immune micro environment using mixed
technology
and i would highly recommend you to see
his presentation as well if you are
interested
in ultra high content imaging focused on
the tumor microenvironment
in this presentation i will focus on the
potential of the mixed technology
on lung cancer research and i will give
you some strategic approaches on the
analysis of such data sets
using our own qi tissue image analysis
software
i hope you enjoy it
let me start with lung cancer lung
cancer is the most common type of cancer
worldwide
and can be divided in small cell lung
cancer and non-small cell lung cancer
this one is the most common type of lung
cancer and
is the leading cause of cancer mortality
worldwide
it can be divided in three subtypes
adenocarcinomas
squamous cell carcinomas and large cell
carcinomas
lung adenocarcinomas and lung squamous
cell carcinomas are the two major
histological subtypes
accounting for almost 70 percent of the
total cases of lung cancer
what differentiates them mainly is where
they begin
the adenocarcinoma begins in the cells
in the glands located in the outer part
of the lung
whereas the majority of cases of
squamous cell carcinoma starts
in the center of the lung
the current treatments for lung cancer
include surgery chemotherapy radiation
targeted therapies and immunotherapy
and have improved a lot in the last few
years
immunotherapy is a quite exciting new
kind of therapy because it uses your
immune cells to fight
the tumor cells it is uh
quite promising and often shows
long-term clinical benefits and even in
some cases a complete recovery
but the major limitations include a very
high variability in response to
treatment and a difficulty in proper
qualification for therapy
so we need to have deeper insights in
the organization and content of the
tumors and this is not only to develop
new kinds of immunotherapy but also to
be able to really identify
which kind of patients would be better
suited for which kind of therapy
and why do we need such deeper insights
so here you have a depiction
of a heterogeneous tumor
microenvironment
a lot of tumor microenvironments are
like this
fairytale genius you don't really know
what's in there and the
thing is that if you look at the regular
imaging um
yeah a regular microscopy image
you normally would not see so much
because you are limited in the amount of
markers that help you recognize the
different kind of cells
and here i have some examples if you go
for tumor or for the immune cells or for
some
other cell types that are often found in
these tumor micro
environments you need a lot a lot of
markers just to characterize them and
this is known this is not something new
so imagine if you need to know more or
to even try to figure out more to define
new markers you would need more than 50
easily
and the maxima imaging system is
actually the only
system that can do so many markers
hundreds of markers in one sample
my imaging system was developed by
meltani biotech
and uses the mix technology to achieve
such high
numbers of markers in the sample
the mix technology stands for maxima
imaging cyclic staining and it's quite
simple to understand
actually the maxima is an automated
system meaning that you just need to put
it in your sample
and your antibodies inside and the
machine will do the rest
it will basically take the sample and
stain it with an antibody image it and
erase the signal and therefore can stain
it with
other antibodies image it and erase it
and repeat this cycle as often as you
need to
in this way we can have hundreds of
markers in a sample
we did was not to just create a system
we created an
entire platform so with the maxima
imaging platform you do not just have a
fully automated instrument
that can perform such amazing kind of
experiments but you have
also everything you need for the full uh
experimental plan so you you have sample
carriers that can adapt four different
kind of samples
you have a huge range of validated
antibodies and we have an
amazing image analysis software which i
will present a bit later on because this
is
how i did all my analysis
particular experiment was done
by imaging more than 150 markers in a
sample of lung adenocarcinoma and a
sample of lung squamous cell carcinoma
and here you have a depiction of it of
the
some of the markers that were used and
you can see how great it is to see so
many different markers of different
cells in
one single sample
i will start this part of the
presentation but not going
into real um real
numerical or graphical analysis but
really to just show you the markers the
more common markers that are used for
uh the identification of cell population
and see how they are organized
between the lung adenocarcinoma and the
squamous cell carcinoma
to see really the difference between
these two kind of samples
i will start to introduce you just an
overview of
how we start the experiment so basically
in this case these were sections were on
the microscopic slide
for that we would use then these
sample carrier the maxwell 4 imaging
frame so we have different sizes but
this one has four cavities basically
and you mount your microscopic slide
here on our imaging frame
and then it will be able the maxima will
be able to stain then because it has the
cavity necessary for it
and we have the sample of adenocarcinoma
in this well and a sample of squamous
cell carcinoma
in this well basically and the
antibodies was the same mix
it was the same used for both they were
all processed at the same time
when you start the um the the maxima
what
it does is that it does an overview
image of or your well
so you can see your sample and then you
can define
the area that you want to image and this
is the reason why you'll see that
the two samples have a different format
because this is the format that was
selected when
the experiment was done
so i will start with the general
overview of the sample so basically what
i made here is a composite with seven
markers seven markers to identify
six most commonly uh described cell
population
in this kind of of tumor
samples so basically on the left you'll
always see the adenocarcinoma
and on the right squamous cell carcinoma
in green you can see the tumor cells
that are sent here by cytokeratine
you can see the t cells stained by cd3
the b
cells by cd20 the myeloid cell stained
by
cd163 and cd15 you see some endothelial
cells
so for the blood vessels with c 202p
and you can see some fibroblasts with
the vimentin
in gray and what you can see here
immediately is that it's it's difficult
to make sense of it immediately but
first you can see directly that they
have a complete
different kind of organization in here
most of the cells seem to be cancer
cells and you have some stroma
area here and you see some infiltration
from t cells and you see that the rest
is basically myeloid cells
fibroblasts and some blood vessels
when you look at the squamous cell
carcinoma you see
that the proportion of
tumor cells or tumor positive cells are
not
so high it would be more on a 50 50
level
you barely see any infiltration of
t cells there you can see that
we have these very weird regions that
seem to be necrotic
areas because the shape and the
intensity of the signal here
is very different from the rest you see
that in the stroma
area you have mainly fibroblasts and
myeloid cells and
almost no blood vessel marker here
so i would say that here we do not have
infiltration apparently
but now focusing only on the t cells so
this
helps visualize it better so now we can
clearly see that there are way more t
cells in the adenocarcinoma and it
doesn't seem to have
much in the squamous cell carcinoma but
let's have a closer look
yeah so here looking at the markers we
can clearly see in this region where we
have
more t cells that uh so first cd3 is
more common
t cell markers so it will be in all t
cells the cd4
is on just on cd um on
t helper cells and the cd8 is more in
cytotoxic t cells cd8 is normally
associated with a better prognostic here
we can see that the majority
in the adenocarcinoma of the t cells are
cd4 but we can see some
cd8 positive cells in this queen of cell
carcinoma though we can see that there
is barely any signal we see some
speckles but i would not
take this as positive cells so i would
say that this
particular sample has no infiltration
now let's have a look at the b cell
marker so c20 is a common beast
a common b cell marker so first on the
adenocarcinoma here
the signal seems a bit weird not a lot
it seems almost that it's speckled so
i'm not sure
how it is when you look at the b cell
that has a very weird pattern it seems
that we have signal in the
nuclei of tumor cells so this is very
weird
first because it is not replicated in
the other sample
and it is the same antibody from the
same mixture and the
samples have been handled the same way
so this is very curious
of course you cannot take any real
conclusion out of it because
further investigation would be needed
for it but i still
wanted to show it because i found this
quite um
interesting and also for the fact that
we have here direct comparison of
of of the markers but let's take a
closer look
so here when we look at it more in depth
we can see that actually here we have
real
signal it's just that there's not many b
cells
in this sample and here again you can
see this very interesting pattern
and again this is very curious because
it's only in the tumor cells it's not on
the other cells and here we actually can
see
a real well an expected pattern of this
antibody
because it stands where it's supposed to
stain so um
i do not think that there's a real
problem at antibody but
we should still this would need to be
figured out in other samples to see if
this happens again or if it's just a one
time or
but it's still very interesting as an
observation
now i'm here showing you some markers
that are used for myeloid cells
so here there are there are a couple so
it's a bit can be a bit overwhelming but
all in all what you can see is that
in the adenocarcinoma it seems that they
are a bit distributed you can see them
um evenly distributed a bit everywhere
not
really clear pattern we see that the
the hla is more um visible here in some
places here but the rest seems to be a
bit um
well distributed when you look at the
squamous cell carcinoma you see that we
see a very
big amount of signal of cd15 in these
necrotic areas
which could make sense and actually you
see that in the stroma area you have the
rest of the markers mainly
there so again based on the other
observations before we could see that
the stroma area of the squamous cell
carcinoma seemed to be constituted
mainly by fibroblasts and myeloid cells
so
it makes kind of sense but we can see
some cd14
areas here around the tumor cells so
this can be very interesting
as well but all in all we see how
different they are
organized
so here i'm looking mainly at the
fibroblast so i used vimentine as a
marker generally for
for general fibroblasts and the other
ones as activating
markers so you can see that first of all
they overlapped the activating marker so
actin is known to be an activating
microscope caldisman and myosin
um can be associated with it
uh because it it kind of is into the
transition
from
[Music]
from the state of activation and
so here what you can see is that we can
clearly see some
specific areas where there seem to be
some
fibroblast activation when ice
activation it is normally
in support in favor of the tumor against
infiltration of immune cells so that's
not very good for prognosis
we can see here that in this area which
coincidentally
we know have some infiltration from the
other
um from the other images so it can be
kind of a reaction of
tumor cells to prevent infiltration to
be to go further on
and here you can also see interestingly
that these activation
areas are very at the border between
the tumor cell and the stroma area so it
could be
um supporting the growth of
the tumor cells
assessing the tumor prolife
proliferation state is also very
important when looking at tumor samples
so
here i used ki 67 and pcna to look
at the proliferative state of these
tumor cells so we can see that all in
all
both samples seem to be quite active we
can see that the under no carcinoma
there are some areas that seems way more
active than
others and we saw before
that there was some t-cell infiltration
as well here it might be that it means
that they're fighting actively
the tumor and that is good in the
squamous cell carcinoma
basically if we forget the necrotic
areas we kind of see that in all the
tumor cells here so the non-necrotic
tumor cells you can see basically
they're all
in a highly proliferation state so this
tumor doesn't
look good
so here i wanted to check the the
environment
of the tumor sample so basically um
pd1 blockade is one kind of therapy that
is commonly used
in in tumor therapy
and what it means is that basically when
we have pd1 and pdl1 and pdl2 which are
the ligands
present in a sample this would suggest
that
the sample has an immunosuppressive
environment meaning that it's not good
for cells
for immune cells to infiltrate to fight
the cancer and here we can see clearly
that
there is the presence of these markers
in the squamous cell carcinoma but not
really in that renal carcinoma which
could be
why there is no really
t cell infiltration for example in this
in this sample
so now i would like to focus mainly on
some strategies
strategies for the analysis of such uh
samples so as you
might understand or might imagine this
kind of that
data can be very overwhelming it is a
lot of markers it's a high
level of content within one sample only
and it can be very overwhelming to
figure out what we really want to
extract from it
so you can start your experiment with
one question in mind but you
you have so much such a high amount
of data inside that it's not uncommon
that you would go back to your data set
to find out other
other conclusions out of it because it
is so rich that it is not meant to just
to answer
one quick question um so in this first
part i will focus on the long
adenocarcinoma
um and with some ideas for you
how you could handle this kind of
analysis and
how you would display such kind of
results
i will start though by introducing our
software here because
uh when acquiring a maxima you will get
the qi tissue image
analysis software and it's a very
complete
and and very nice tool
to use for ultra high content
image analysis it has been developed for
such kind
for this kind of dataset especially and
it offers a very
variety of features and here i just want
to show you a couple of them for you to
have an idea where the software looks
like
so basically you can easily see all your
markers from your run so this is a very
nice way to visualize
all your data there is also segmentation
integrated so you can
with a click in a couple of parameters
just start and have directly the
segmentation and segmentation is crucial
to define
the cell nucleus and the cell boundaries
to give an identity
uh to a certain area to a cell identity
so then you can correlate
cells with markers expression and
location etc
with this software it is highly
interactive so when you do for example
gating strategies which our flow
cytometers are
cytometrists are very familiar with um
you can do it uh like you are used to
but the the plus here is that you
actually
see which cells you are selecting you
see them
lighting up on the tissue and you can
also do gating
within the tissue sample so you can
select the cells and you can see them
light up
in your graph as well and of course
there's integrated
variety of visualization modes for your
data to
better explain the data that you're
extracting
so let me start with the first strategy
based on the observation that
was made by looking through the most
common cell markers as we did before
um i concluded that the adenocarcinoma
sample
was mainly constituted by tumor cells t
cells fibroblasts and macrophages
so in this strategy i decided uh what
kind of cells i wanted to look into and
how i would group them so first i
started by doing a very simplistic uh
gating strategy so this can be of course
more complex depending on where you come
from and what
your objectives of these samples are but
this
i wanted to provide an easy to grasp
clustering um not clustering gating
method
and for that i uh started by selecting
the tumor cells versus the t
cells and then i said that the rest of
the cells would then be
fibroblasts and macrophages then i gated
on a histogram the fibroblast based on
the vimentine
and then used the rest of the cells as
macrophages so as i said it's a very
simplistic
there's a certain ways to do it better
of course but this is a very
easy way to explain it after doing this
kind of gating strategy
you could actually see the cells you are
selecting so i could directly see
the cells i selected and assign them a
color
and the name of course and see them on
the image
you can also get the information about
the number and the percentage of cells
as well getting strategy what i wanted
to do with it
was to define how these different
populations were
organized in relation to each other so
what i did was i created a distance map
so with this distance maps you guessed
basically an image where the higher the
gray value
the higher the distance from the cells
of interest you are
so i created four of these maps and then
plotted them against the cells as well
to define how they were organized which
ones were closer together and which ones
were furthest away together and
based on this i could see that the
macrophages seem to be closer to the
tumor area
whereas the t cells furthest away and
the fibroblasts seem to be intermediate
so this could suggest that actually in
this
adrenal carcinoma the cells are not
managing the t cells are not managing to
infiltrate as much as we could
at as much as we wanted to and that
actually maybe the fibroblasts are there
to preventing them to go since they
don't manage to pass them
as a second strategy here i wanted to
include
a quite a different feature that you
wouldn't have
by doing flow cytometry which is really
to look at the shape
of the cells you're looking at so when
you look at
the uh so here you have the dappy in
gray
with the green being the cytokeratin to
the
the tumor cells but you can also see
just the dappy image here and you can
see clearly that you can identify the
non-tumor cells just by looking at the
nucleus
at least some areas the nuclei of the
tumor cell is very irregular
and is even has lower intensities one
seems to have holes they seem to be
hollow
so this is a feature that is actually
extracted from our data so that can be
plotted against each other
so i decided here to plot the
nucleus roundness versus the
cytokeratine to really create
uh four kind of groups so the round and
cytokeratine negative cells the round
and cytokeratine positive cells the
irregular site and
versus the irregular and cytokeratine
negative
and the irregular and the cytokeratine
positive cells and see
if i could see the differences between
these four
um
so i decided to plot all the markers i
had in this run
in um in a heat map to just have a
better overlook and then have the
possibility to go further into it
but here i will just stay here this is a
strategy for you to
imagine how to handle this kind of data
so first of all i could see that
the round and healthy so the round and
cytokeratine negative cells seem to have
most of the um of the immune cell
markers such as
the cd2 cd5 cd4
cd3 and cd8 also so this could be seen
here actually quite nicely
we could see that the cytokeratin
negative cell
had levels of cd6e and cd
162 which are related to
a kind of inflammation state of the
immune cell so that's
also very interesting we could see that
cd147
was more present in the cytokeratine
positive
cells but it's slightly a bit more in
the brown one so it might be that
they're not
directly already final tumor cells but
on the verge or
or contacting with them and cd147
is actually a rising star in in the
target
uh research because it's thought to be
very good
um that could be actually a potential
nice
drug target um it is involved in the
extracellular protein is
inducement so it induces extra cellular
proteinases which helps the tumor grow
in theory
you can see also here the cytokeratine
is nicely differentially expressed and
you could see that
the cytokeras in positive cells seem to
have more hsp70 and pi3k which is
related with a higher activity which is
common in um
in proliferating cells
so these were my two strategies for the
lung adenocarcinoma
sample and here i would like to focus
more on the squamous cell carcinoma
since they had such different kind of
organization i thought they were perfect
examples to have different strategies
associated with them
so for the squamous cell carcinoma first
i wanted to
show again the different organization
of these of this tumor basically
here you can see that i have four
markers
plus the dappy showing the tumor cells
in green with the cytokeratine the
vimentine for
the fibroblasts and the cd163 and the
cd68
for the myeloid cells and you can
clearly see that you can
distinguish three different areas so we
have the stromal
area which is with non-tumor cells we
have the tumor
cells and then we have these necrotic
areas we have
some tumor cell markers who have some
myeloid cell
markers that seem to be really not that
healthy as well and do not have
proliferation markers for example and
have these very weird speckles
what i decided to do here
so i decided to do here was to uh
first do an image gating strategy so i
really like just to draw
these regions and selected them as the
necrotic areas
and then i quickly um just
gated the tumor cell positives with
cytokeratine versus the rest
and to separate them in these three
major categories
and then i decided to go for a
overview look a screening
so i call it screening method every time
that
i am doing a heat map because i found
the heat night the best way to have a
overlook of what's going on especially
when you're comparing different cells
um so for example in this case you could
see that
the necrotic area seem to have a lower
amount of cytoskeletal proteins compared
to the tumor which would make sense if
they're dying they're not
reproducing they're not making new
building blocks for the new cells
we have also uh galactins who are lower
and they are
associated with proliferative style as
well so it makes sense that they're more
they are higher in the tumor and we know
that this
uh tumor selection because we excluded
the necrotic areas right
that are more proliferative and you can
actually see this clearly
in the ki 67 npcna area
we could see also that high levels of 66
variants were present in a necrotic area
which is
often associated with an inflammation so
it would make sense that the necrotic
area would be highly inflammated
and we can also see that there are high
levels of cd15 and amyloid a
uh they're suggesting that these
necrotic areas have high
inflammation going on and some recycling
of the membranes and
might be some digesting of the necrotic
cells there
based on the same guiding strategy of
before so by the
the image gate of the necrotic areas
and the tumor versus non-tumor
areas getting here um based on that
particular getting strategy i decided
here for the second strategy to just
do a distance map of the tumor
um of the tumor cells so basically what
i wanted to
show here is to define which are the
cells who are
more in contact with the tumor versus
the cells who are
further away and once you create this
kind of maps what you can do is that
you can plot it so for example here i
have the intensity of the pig cells
and and i can plot the ones who are
lower intensity
means that they are closer to my tumor
cells and the ones who are a higher
intensity that will be here for example
will be furthest away and when you plot
them here i use the same coloring and
here you can see them
plotted so you can see them selected
here
in the um sample you can see that the
pink ones are the ones really
surrounding the tumor areas and then the
green ones are really in these areas
where they're furthest away
from all kinds of cancer cells and here
you could see then that they uh
showed to be to have different markers
expressed actually
you could see that for example here we
have some cd 38 and cd 147 very active
cd38
interacts with extracellular proteins
and as i said before cd147
is a an extracellular protein is inducer
so you can explain that helps these are
the cells that helps the
tumor cell expand we see some cd66 here
so
correlates with inflammation from the
cells who are not tumor cells so they
can
be not in an inflammatory state
we also have um jack one here and
sick here also uh related
to uh inflammation and here we actually
can see a nice gradient where we see
that there is
um more tubulin so more alpha tubulin
close to the tumor region and less and
less
as you go further the way this can be a
relation to the activated set so the
proliferating state that we can see
that closer to the tumor there is more
active cells who are
either moving a lot or um or
dividing a lot and therefore they would
need more tubulin
and i would like to now present a very
quick
last strategy so of course you can do
all these manual gatings as well just
to um to choose the cells that you
already
know are there that exist and observe
how they organize between each other
and what kind of content they have in it
but when you do not know and you want to
figure out
if there are some different uh groups of
subtypes of
a cell for example in this case here uh
subtypes of tumor cells what you can
go for is a more unbiased strategy
where you would look at the different
clusters
um of the tumor cells based on on the
markers that you wished for so over here
what i did was that i did a k-means
clustering of the tumor cells
only in the hope to get some um
interesting clusters to identify and
maybe
define new subtypes of your of the
cancer
of the tumor cells and basically after
plotting it
i also need a disney plot these kind of
plots helps you to have an overview of
this
of how the cells are organized in
between each other
and here you can see clearly where uh
these cluster falls and so cluster one
here
cluster two here cluster three here
um and so on and so forth and then what
i did is like i plotted this
these clusters in a heat map also again
to have an overview
one example here is that you see that
cluster one four and five which are the
biggest ones do not seem to have
uh stand up standouts but it might be to
the fact
that these two clusters because they're
very small uh stand out
better and then kind of um make
the other differences not as visible so
in a case here we could do is then just
plot these three uh clusters between
each other ignoring these two to see the
the big difference between them of
course when you have smaller cluster
chances are
that you're going to see bigger
differences
and here as you can see you can see some
of the cells the the blue cells
here and the green ones are very little
amount you can barely see them so this
might be just a
this might be just a very very specific
kind of cells and in this case
here what i could see is that
cytokeratine 14
was high only in this kind of cluster
um as well as podoplanine so this is
quite interesting so i do not
know um so cytokeratine 14 would be more
in epithelial cell polar planning could
be also
so this is interesting now we have in
the cluster 2
amyloid a who seems to get higher
and gfap for example which is quite
interesting because these are
normally to be neuronal markers and in
this case they are not so
uh because there are tumor cells in the
lung so this is
uh something that could be looked at
into more deeply
and here you can see that these clusters
seem to have the highest amount of all
the cytokeratines compared to the three
clusters and these are only tumor cells
so this is quite example we should have
then we could have a further look into
these clusters and
dig into a bit more but this is general
these are general strategies that i
wanted to present to you
uh to get uh an overview of what you can
do
when you have these data at least the
first steps to start understanding what
your data has
so basically i hope that you enjoyed
this presentation
i wanted to show again the potential
when it comes to ultra high content
data that is can only be generated with
the maxima at this level with hundreds
of markers
and you can make such nice presentations
and content
using our qitshu software
for the analysis of these data sets
there has already
very many features that are needed for
this kind of
of analysis
so the just as a summary i would like to
say again that the maxima imaging
platform
really allows for an unprecedented
number of markers
in a single sample and it's really
breathtaking when you look at all the
markets that you can see in one
sample only the ultra high content
imaging opens the door to a var variety
of
analysis approaches so i gave a couple
of examples here but
really the sky is your limit it depends
really what you want to
find out or sometimes you don't even
know what you want to find out and you
can find out
great things just with this rich data
sets
like i said it won't be um
uncommon to go back to your experiment
and
uh have other outputs out of it once you
are done with the research question that
you had before when you did the
experiment
you can always focus initially on the t
cells and then go on to tumor cells and
so on
and the kind of the way you look at your
data
can change and you can really give you
different outputs
this software allows for multiple
analysis strategies very complete and
very convenient to use and easy to use
and elegant
and as you can see you can get quite a
lot
out of it so just wanted to finish by
showing again this nice uh animation
where you can see all the markers
um and uh i would like to
take this moment to thank everyone that
is involved in this
such as our researcher our application
development team and also
our developers for qi tissue
this is really um this has been great
and
we are making a great
great products here to really enable
research to another level
i would like to now also thank you for
your attention
and
i'll be happy to take some questions
thank you
thank you dr santos for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
let's get started our first question
is
is there a way to check histology in
field
yes so currently the maxima does not
have a bright field image
generated what we normally use is the
dappy signal to check the um
the way the the tissue is
um so currently we cannot do bright
fields
okay thank you dr santos for our next
question is
is it possible to have an idea of the
computation time for calculating
distances
defining areas etc plus experimental
time
that is a great question that can be
also a bit
complicated to answer so basically um
i believe that what takes most time is
looking at your data set especially when
you have such huge data sets
it takes some time to look at it to
really um
see what works what didn't work um what
is the
the markers that already have my
interest
and everything just to go through it and
have a strategy
in your mind already so what is my aim
what do i need
to um to analyze what is my current
interest because as i said you can have
really different outputs depending on
how you look at your data set
the part that i showed here
once you i decided which strategy i
wanted to go was very very fast
the generation of maps is very
um very fast uh in your
in qi tissue for example so it's it can
take time but it's not it's like the
decisive
is not from the software it is not
from the um from the
the maxima itself there's the time that
will take what we'll take more time to
do is to
define what you want once it is it's
quite fast the the software is fast and
also
depending on how big is your uh data set
your computer can
be a bit faster or not but in general
uh for sure it's it's really fast so
that was a general
so the image there of the distances
was generated in three seconds
thank you dr santos next question
do you use markers or nuclei shape to
define necrotic areas
but in this one particularly what i did
was just
checking at the nuclei because it was
quite
uh strong so all this very pointy
and very strong signal i didn't check
specifically for markers
okay let's see
is it possible is it only possible to
look at
rois rather than full tissue sections
uh so you define your roi uh it will
it will depend on your choice so if you
want to select the full
uh section you can as long as it fits
into
uh our disposable so our biggest
disposable
is the maxwell one and you can have most
of the portion of your microscope fly
there
but of course you will have to consider
that this will take more time
because of all the the imaging
processing
and also the experiment to be done but
it's possible yes
okay thank you dr santos next question
uh what is the max size of a scanning
area
and what is the speed of scanning and
resolution of the images
uh so as i just said if you use our um
maxwell one which is the one with the
bigger area
you could in theory do a bit more than
900
square millimeters um but of course you
have to consider the
the party that you will take more time
because you will have to acquire
multiple field of views our best
resolution
currently is um a bit more than 400
nanometers
with one of our objectives and the time
will really depend on a lot your
configuration of your experiments so the
shortest
possible cycle could be around 30
minutes
but it will depend on how how many
antibodies you have
um in one cycle how many field reviews
you have so
it it depends on a very variety of
parameters
okay great thank you so much for that
answer next question here
how many antibodies are used per cycle
and what chemistry is used for signal
removal
so currently we can use uh up to three
antibodies in one cycle
a plus the ducky signal and in terms of
signal erasure we have uh so on one head
we use photobleaching and that is why we
have the
fluorophores that we have and we can
also do another mechanisms based on our
lease technology to develop that male
penny
and this is a controlled fluorochrome
release
of the antibody of the fluorophore
sorry okay thank you
and next question let's see um
are the antibodies used in a same
directly conjugated
is amplification used and are those
antibodies proprietary or
common clones
so the antibodies we used are primarily
conjugated
antibodies so there's no signal
amplification
and we so when in our rng we mostly use
melt any antibodies of course who are
mixed validated
but you can use a any antibody
as long as it fulfills some requirement
which is
the fact that it can be stained
in 10 minutes because that's the process
in the maxima
and it can be and
it is conjugated to apc fizzy or pe
because
these are the 404s for which our
photo bleaching is currently
set up for
okay thank you next question are these
2d whole slide images or do you have to
select
an roi before image acquisition
so when you when you start the the
the software the maxima will do an
overview scan of the whole well
and then there you can select uh one roi
or multiple otherwise or
a very big region of interest this is
totally
your choice in this particular case also
i showed in one of the slides
it was uh just one region
so in the adenocarcinoma we had about
18 field of views and in the squamous
cell carcinoma was about 16 field of
views
we've got time for a few more questions
here and our next
question what is the resolution that can
be achieved with this technology
uh so we have two objectives one that
can image through the microscope slides
which
can achieve around 600 nanometers
and one for very thin glass you can
achieve
around 20 around 400 nanometers
okay thank you dr santos our next
question
i would like to know if only antibodies
validated by milton knee can be used
with the machine and if this is the case
um is there a plan to expand to
non-optimized antibodies
um so of course we will always um
say that validated antibodies are a bit
better and i'm sure everyone understands
the struggle
of validating a certain antibody
but the maxima is an open system so as i
said you just have to fulfill a few
requirements you
just have to get the antibody that you
want conjugated to one of the
fluorophores
and make sure on your hand that you have
tested it for
a same duration of 10 minutes and uh
define the title yourself but after that
you could just have it
on your antibody plate for example
and the maxima will will make sure it's
it's used in the cycle
so it's not close to only built any
validated antibodies
okay thank you dr santos looks like we
have one more
question here can you quantify the
signal intensity as well
so yes of course the images are all
acquired and processed and then once you
have an imaging
uh software program that can open
uh t files which is virtually all
image programs you will have there the
the signal quantification with your gray
values
all right well thank you dr santos um
do you have any final comments for our
audience before we go
uh yes so i would like to say that i
hope first that uh everyone enjoyed
the presentation uh and i could convey a
bit more information about what our
platform can do not only in terms of the
technology itself but also show you some
examples of how you can handle
uh such kind of data and how you can
think about
the extra the data that you want to
extract
from your experiments and i
hope that you could see also that with
qi t-shirt you could
achieve a lot of interesting outputs
there's a lot more and again it always
depends on what kind of questions you
have
and what you want to answer it might be
then that you can get
new questions just by looking at your
data
i just also wanted to say that there's
always more to come
that you can always follow us on our
social media and
check our websites for the latest news
um and of course if you have more
interest do not hesitate in contacting
us for more questions
regarding the maxima platform so
everything but from the instrument from
everything we offer thank you again for
participating in the webinar and
i hope to see you in the next one
well thank you again dr santos for your
time today
and for your important research we would
also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor
milton yi biotech for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
libraries will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye